plenty more from the Westminster
accounts over the next few days we're
keeping across a developing story in
Brazil coming out of the Brazilian
Capital where protesters have broken
into government buildings this video uh
we've just obtained from an eyewitness
outside the parliament in Brasilia
supporters of the former far-right
president Zaire bolsonaro have invaded
the Supreme Courts the Congress building
and surrounded the presidential Palace
in Brasilia it all is an echo isn't it
of the January the sixth invasion of the
U.S capital by supporters of President
Donald Trump now several thousand
protesters were being told have broken
into buildings smashing Furniture inside
the Supreme Court and the Congress local
media estimating about 3 000 people were
involved far-right supporters of
bolsonaro have been demanding a military
coup
since he lost the presidential election
back in October many dispute the result
now this area that you can see on screen
around the Parliament building had been
cordoned off but protesters managed to
break through March past security and
get into some of those buildings the
current president president Lula de
Silva is in Sao Paulo for the weekend so
isn't present we're keeping across that
story of course throughout the evening